In my most recent cheek swab you told me to begin eating 130 to 150 grams of protein a day. This seems overwhelming. I know, I know it hurts, I know it hurts. It's very overwhelming.
What are good ways of getting protein in your diet over the course of the day.
I have been elated one, four, oh, serving a meat a day for 18 months. So just all of the research that has been coming out about.
Grants of protein necessary to stimulate lymphocyte function.
So the order you could have normal white blood cell count on a CBC.
Normal lymphocyte count on a CBC. But we're talking about lymphocyte function is completely dependent on protein levels.
And the research coming out is when you increase protein levels, you increase the activity of natural killer cells and your T cells, which are so important, which are everything when it comes to killing cancer.
So we've really changed our tool in the last six months and written some blog posts about this about what is what has been shown to increase activity is when you eat the number of grams of protein.
So if you wait 200 pounds, you should eat 200 grams of protein a day. And that seems overwhelming. It's almost impossible if you're a vegetarian. It's very, very difficult.
So I just want you to strive to that as you're going to take some working up to that and make sure if you haven't been eating a lot of meat and you start eating some meat.
That you do incorporate some digestive enzymes with your meals, because you don't want to get constipated.
So if your system has not been accustomed to eating a lot of protein, you may need some digestive enzymes to help with the breakdown of that protein so you absorb it better.
So just work towards there.